[Music]
your brain is one of your most important
organs home to billions of neurons it's
your body's mission
control as you go through life your body
changes
radically inside your head your most
complex organ is constantly transforming
too beginning work before you're born
and continuing even after you've been
declared
dead this is the life cycle of your
brain
[Music]
your brain starts to form about 2 weeks
after
conception on one side of the developing
embryo the cells thicken to form what is
called the neural
plate around week four this folds over
onto itself forming a tube which
ultimately creates the nervous
system every minute from the time the
neural tube closes your brain is growing
hundreds of nerve cells called
neurons at Birth your brain contains
about 100 billion neurons more than an
adult this gives the baby the best
chance of developing a healthy
brain the excess neurons are shed before
you become an
adult but what you don't have is a lot
of shapses the point of contact where
electronic signals are passed between
neurons which in turn change the
behavior of the
neurons some neurons become insulated by
a fatty substance called myelin these
neurons known as white matter are able
to transmit information faster between
brain areas allowing more complex
processes to take
place when you're born the average
number of copses per neuron is
2,500 but that's increases to
approximately 15,000 per neuron over the
first few years of your life as your
neurons mature and create new
copses the speed at which they form
copses could be one reason children find
it easier to learn things like languages
or musical
instruments it's also why children's
experiences in this phase can have
lasting effects on their
development from 3 until about 10 your
brain starts to remove connections it no
longer needs neuroscientists used to
think all copses worked at a constant
fixed level but now they understand that
copses can be strengthened or weakened
depending on how they are
used this is known as
neuroplasticity it's essentially your
brain's way of making sure it's more
efficient with experience and and
absorbs new
information if you're enjoying this film
and want to read more of our coverage
why not take out a subscription to The
Economist you'll receive daily and
weekly analysis of global Affairs you
can read us online in the app or listen
to the audio Edition for the best offer
click the
link by the time you become a teenager
your brain has stopped growing but it
continues to
develop the insulation of the neurons
which begins at Birth continues over
many years it starts at the back of the
brain and moves forward so different
parts of your brain develop at different
rates areas associated with reward like
the ventral striatum develop faster than
the prefrontal cortex which is linked to
self-control and
rationality teens also experience major
changes in their lyic system the part of
the brain that controls emotions
all this might explain why teenagers
experience more mood swings than
adults neuroscientists believe the
difference in development between the
emotion-driven part of the brain and the
rational part may also be the reason
teenagers are more likely to take risks
or experience addiction compared with
adults puberty also brings with it
increased activity in The Venture medial
prefrontal cortex the part of the brain
that relates to
self-evaluation this change can improve
teenagers understanding of social
interactions and their ability to form
friendships but it might also make them
more susceptible to social
[Music]
anxiety post puberty the brain continues
to develop brain tissue in the
prefrontal cortex increases connections
joining the emotional and motor
centers your brain reaches full
development by your 30s and white matter
reaches the highest volume at about 40
but it's not all downhill from
there as you age plasticity allows your
brain to keep changing and
adapting research has shown older adults
are more likely to use both sides of the
brain for short-term memory rather than
just the left brain
hemisphere middle-aged brains have also
learned to minimize the
negative scientists have found the
amydala the part of the brain that deals
with emotion lights up when younger
people look at both positive and
negative
images but for older adults it reacts
much less when shown negative
images this might be because as you age
you become more
resilient Decades of experience in
dealing with difficult situations
activates neural Pathways which can be
used when you experience a similar
[Music]
situation for those who go through the
menopause changes to the amount of
estrogen affect brain energy consumption
producing symptoms like hot flushes and
mood swings
the volume of white matter also falls
and doesn't recover but despite this
those who are postmenopausal have higher
structural connectivity between some
brain regions than those who don't go
through the menopause meaning that the
connections in those regions may become
more
efficient the point at which your brain
begins to slow down depends on your
genes but on the whole studies show that
the slowing process begins in your 30s
and 40s before accelerating in your 60s
and
70s As you move into later life your
cerebral cortex which is the outer layer
of the brain
thins this is particularly noticeable in
the frontal lobe and the hippocampus
which are important for memory emotions
and
navigation your white matter shrinks and
the Brain generates fewer chemical
Messengers such as dopamine and
serotonin which leads to slower
cognitive
processing until very recently
neuroscientists didn't know what happens
to your brain when you
die but by chance doctors were recording
the brain waves of a patient when he
died of a heart attack they found a
change in a specific band of brain waves
involved in high cognitive functions
such as concentrating dream dreaming and
memory
retrieval suggesting that just before
you die your brain may recall important
life events which may explain why those
who have near-death experiences report
seeing their lives Flash before them and
your brain doesn't stop working even
when you're
dead some Studies have found that brain
activity may continue for several
minutes even after your heart has
stopped
[Music]
if you'd like to read more on the brain
then click the link thanks for watching
and don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe